So to me, a developer machine learning researcher,
how do I let Freeman participate in this competition? And how do others,
I'm sure there'll be a lot of others interested in participating in this
competition. What are, uh, let's see, there's like a million questions,
but like first one is how do I get started?
Well, you can go to numer.ai, sign up, download the data.
And on the data is pretty small. Um,
in the data pack you download, there's like an example,
script Python scripts that just builds a XG boost model very
quickly from the data. Uh, and, um,
so in a very short time, you can have an example model.
Is it a particular structure? Like what, uh.
Is this model then submitted somewhere?
So there's needs to be some kind of structure that communicates with some kind
of API. Like how does the whole odd is that your model?
Once you built the wants to create a little, little baby Frankenstein,
how does it then live in?
Yeah. Well,
we want you to keep your baby Frankenstein at home and take care of it.
We don't want it. Okay. So we, you never upload your model to us. You always,
um, only giving us predictions. So we never see the code that wrote your model,
which is pretty cool. Yeah. Our whole hedge fund is built from models.
We've never ever seen the code. Um,
but it's important for the users because it's their IP.
They want to give it to us as brilliant. So they've got it themselves,
but they can basically almost like license the predictions from that.
Um, so think about it. What some users do is they set up a, uh,
compute server. We call it numeric compute.
It's like a little AWS kind of image and you can automate this process.
Um, so we can ping you. We can be like, we need more predictions now,
and then you, you send it to us.
Okay, cool. So th that's, uh, is that described somewhere,
like what the preferred is the AWS or whether another cloud platform
is there, I mean,
is there sort of specific technical things you want to say that comes to mind
that, uh, is a good path for getting started? So download the data,
maybe play around, see if, uh,
you can modify the basic, uh,
the algorithm provided in the
example, and then you,
what set up a little server on AWS that then runs this model and takes
pings and then makes predictions. And, uh,
how does your own money actually come into play, doing the stake of,
um, uh, cryptocurrency?
Yeah. So you don't have to stake.
You can start without staking and many users might try for months, uh,
without staking,
anything at all to see if their model works on the real life data. Right.
And is not overfit. Um, but then, uh, you can get numeraire,
uh, many different ways you can buy it on. Um, you can buy some on Coinbase.
You can buy some on unit swap, you can buy some on Binance. Um.
So w what did you say? This is, uh, how do you pronounce it?
So this is the new MRI, uh, cryptocurrency NMR, NMR.
You just say NMR.
It is technically called numeraire numeraire. Yeah,
but NMR is simple.
[Inaudible] okay. So, and you could buy it, uh, you know, basically anywhere.
Yeah. So it's a bit strange. Cause sometimes people be like, is this like,
pay to play? Right. And it's like, sore. It's like, yeah,
you need to put some money down to show us, you believe in your model,
but weirdly we're, we're not selling you the car. Like,
you can't buy the cryptocurrency from us. Right. It's like,
it's also, we never, if you're, if you do badly, um,
we destroy your cryptocurrency. Okay. That's not good. Right.
You don't want it to be destroyed,
but what's good about it is it's also not coming to us. Right.
So it's not like we win when you lose or, or something like that. Like,
we're the house, like, we're definitely on the same team. Yes.
You're helping us make a hedge fund. That's never been done.
Yeah. So again, interests are aligned. There's no, uh,
there's no tension there at all,
which is really fascinating given away everything.
And then the IP is owned by the sort of the, the code. You never share the code.
That's fascinating. Um,
so since I have you here and you said a hundred,
I didn't ask I out of how many, so we'll just, but if, uh,
if I, then once he gets started and you find this interesting,
uh, how do you then win or do well,
but also how do you potentially try to, when,
if this is something you want to take on seriously from the machine learning
perspective, not from a financial perspective.
Yeah. I think, um, the first of all, you want to talk to the community.
People are pretty open. Uh,
we give out really interesting scripts and ideas for things you might want to
try. Um, and, uh,
but you also going to need a lot of compute probably.
And so some of the best users are, are, you know,
actually the very first time someone, one on numerous,
I would re I wrote them a personal email. It's like, you know,
you've won some money. We're so excited to give you $300. And then they said,
I spend way more on the computer. Um, but.
It's fundamentally a machine learning problem. First, I think is,
this is one of the exciting things I don't know,
full in how many ways you can approach this,
but really this is less about kind of
no offense, but like finance people, finance minded people. They're also,
I'm sure great people,
but it feels like from the community that I've experienced,
these are people who see finances, a fascinating, uh,
problem, space, a source of data,
but ultimately they're machine learning people or AI people,
which is a very different kind of flavor of community. And, um, I mean, I,
I should say to that, uh,
I I'd love to participate in this and I will participate in this.
And I'd love to hear from other people, if you're listening to this,
if you're a machine learning person, you should participate in it. And tell me,
uh, give me some hints, um, how I can, uh, do well at this thing.
Cause this boomer, uh, I'm not sure I still got it, but cause some of it is,
uh, it's like a Kaggle competitions.
Like some of it is certainly set ideas,
like research ideas and like fundamental innovation,
but I'm sure some of it is like deeply understanding getting like an intuition
about the data.
And then like a lot of it will be like figuring out like what works like tricks.
I mean, you could, you could argue most of the deep learning research,
it's just tricks on top of tricks, but there's, uh,
there's some of it is just the art of getting to know how to work in a really
difficult machine learning problem.
And I think what's important,
the important difference with something like a Kaggle competition where they'll
set up this kind of toy problem, and then they will be an out of sample test,
like, Hey, you did well out of sample. And this is like, okay, cool. Um,
but what's cool with memorize your, your,
the out of sample is the real livestock market. We,
we don't even know, like we don't know the answer to the problem with it.
We don't like you'll have to find out live. And so we've had users who've,
who've like submitted every week for, for like four years. Um,
because it's kind of a intro. It,
we say it's the hardest data science problem on the planet. Right.
And it's that sense?
Maybe it sounds like maybe a bit too much for like a marketing thing,
but it's the hardest, because it's the stock market. It's like,
literally there are like billions of dollars at stake and like, no,
one's like letting it be inefficient on purpose.
So if you can find something that works a Numerai,
you really have something that, that is like working on the real stock market.
Yeah. Because there's like humans involved in the stock market mean this, uh,
you know, you could argue them might be harder data sets ag,
maybe predicting the weather, all those kinds of things. But the,
the fundamental statement here is which I, like, I was thinking like,
is this really the hardest data size problem? And you start thinking about that,
but ultimately it also boils down to a problem where the data is
accessible. It's made accessible,
made really easy and efficient at like
submitting algorithms. So it's not just, you know,
it's not about the data being out there,
like the weather it's about making the data super accessible,
making the ability to community around it.
Like this is what imaging that did exactly. Like it's not just,
there's always images. The point is you aggregate them together.
You give it a little, this is a community. And that's,
that was one of the hardest right. For a time, uh,
and most important data science problems in the world, uh,
because it was accessible because it was, uh, made, uh,
sort of like there was a mechanisms by which like standards
and mechanisms by which to judge your performance,
all those kinds of things and memorize the excess step up from that.
Is there something more you can say about why, from your perspective,
it's the hardest, uh, problem in the world? I mean,
you said it's connected to the market.
So if you can find a pattern in the market,
that's a really difficult thing to do because a lot of people are trying to do
it.
Exactly. But there's also the,
the biggest one is it's it's non-stationary time series.
We've tried to regularize the data. So you can find patents, uh,
by, by doing certain things to the features and the targets,
but ultimately you're in a space where you don't,
there's no guarantees that the out of sample distributions will, uh,
conform to any of the training data and,
and every single, um, era which we call on the website,
like every single era in the data, which is like,
sort of showing you the order of the time. Um,
it's it's even the draining data is, has the same, same dislocations.
And, um, so yeah. It's and then, so, and then there's,
yeah. There's so many things that might, um, might, you might want to try this,
this, like, there's unlimited possible number of models. Right. Um, and so
by, by having it be open, uh,
we can at least search that space.